nostalgia critic cannot be here right
now due to recent some vengeance but he
has letter recording before he left for
you to enjoy
well I'm a nostalgia critic I remember
it so you don't have to our childhoods
kicked ask why because we were a
generation raised by television and
television had cartoons and kids love
cartoons hence we love television but
what were the best nostalgic cartoons
what were the ground breakers of the 80s
and 90s the biggest innovations that
shows everyone tried to rip off but can
never quite duplicate I don't know but
that doesn't mean I can't make up a top
11 list that claims that I do why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the best of memory
length the cream of the crop the
ultimate of Ultimates this is the top 11
animated nostalgic TV shows
you
number eleven
Ghostbusters even though it was based on
the movie Ghostbusters was a very
original very funny and sometimes even
very scary cartoon show I always had a
theory that kids like being scared more
than they let on so as long as there's a
bunch of funny lines and action
sequences to go along with it chances
are you'll have a really fun and
inventive kid show it was kind of like
being a fireman except instead of
putting out fires who were chasing
ghosts which is a hell of a lot cooler
in every episode you would see a new
ghost and every one of them was well
thought out and creatively designed and
of course the Ghostbusters themselves
were incredibly funny capturing the
personalities of the movie to a tee and
of course their slider I really fucking
hated Slimer but everyone else seemed to
like him so what can you do
despite the flight's nut ball
Ghostbusters was a heck of a lot fun if
there's something strange in the
neighborhood you know who to call
number ten
Fox's Peter Pan and the Pirates would
think a TV show shown every day about
Peter Pan would be anything to get
worked up over but the fact of the
matter is this show was very well put to
go what made it so great is they didn't
look like in any other reincarnation to
Peter Pan but to be honest I think it's
the closest it's ever come to the
original JM Barrie story the characters
were fleshed out the stories were well
developed and the creative logic was
actually pretty clever
for example there's an episode where
paying steals the shadows from all the
Pirates because of this they lose their
balance and have to walk upside down
that strangely kind of makes sense
there's another episode where they
actually make cloud sculptures in the
sky dude that's just fucking cool plus a
heads in Korean skeptical seriously how
can you go wrong disgrace the Jolly
Roger today's come and I'll lay your
bones back it's not easy having a good
time you know and of the pirates coulda
been up she'd knock off that only lasted
a few episodes but they put a lot of
time and effort into it and created
something really original as well as
stay true to the original story all of
this is more than enough for Peter Pan's
in the number 10 spot
DuckTales even though Disney had a few
shows like this before and a lot more
shows after ducktales was the first
Disney cartoon to combine some of our
favorite childhood character to an
old-fashioned adventure it was mostly a
treasure hunt show which meant it led to
a lot of creative locations as well as
some cool booby traps it was kind of
like in the other jokes but with ducks
it didn't need a pop cultural references
or subtle in jokes it's just relied on
good old-fashioned characters having
good old-fashioned adventures and of
course did we forget the catchiest theme
song of all time it will never leave it
never leave plus how does scrooge mcduck
dive into all that money without
breaking his skull as he converts dollar
bills yet little questions like this
don't really do the answering when
you're having boodles of feather
flinging fun duck tails it will never
leave
number
ren & stimpy this protune was just nuts
the animation was insane the voices were
insane the stories were insane and we
loved every minute this is pretty much
what kids saw when they were on sugar
absolute madness mixed with undiluted
ng it was so chaotic that even the
characters didn't always look like like
here's Stimpy a one scene and here he
isn't another they don't even look like
the same species or how about some of
these weird jokes I'm so happy
hey let's go dude nice thing why the
hell is the word go in his mouth for a
second or how about the scene where when
I Ernst Indies underwear
okay first of all why does tippy wear
underwear when he wears no other clothes
why does he just place it over his
crotch and not actually wear them and
why does it suddenly look and sound like
a 1950s film strip I don't know nobody
knows it's just that kind of insanity
that made this show crazy and fun to
watch it also puts the boundaries of
what kids shows could do with
controversial episodes like the electric
fence or strange lines like something
came out of my butt
or how about weird morals like wetting
the bed is nothing to be ashamed of you
and I still do it yeah this was a weird
weird show just the kind of kinetic
energy ludicrous logic and crude humor
the kids know and love Brennan sting if
you didn't like it
you're an idiot yo sick little monkey
Mercer
geojo if Barbie was considered an
all-girl phenomenon that geojo was
definitely the all voice phenomena this
show embodied everything that boys want
to see when they grow up action heroes
get guys with guns to work kick-ass here
some huge freaking vehicles and
professional wrestling sergeant
slaughter so much celebrate by giving
away sergeant slaughter action figures
now the showing characters were kind of
bland but let's face it we didn't watch
it better characters we watched it for
the action it's like somebody made a
show out of the army game that we were
already playing it's kids if some1 made
of cowboys and Indians show at that time
my guess is it would do well too if it
had to with all its five work military
command and action-packed adventure GI
Joe knew how to give the bloodthirsty
marine and every little point exactly
what we wanted
Oh
numbers
transforms it's no wonder that one of
the best marketing ideas of all time but
also one of the best anime it shows
again kind of tailoring to every voice
indulging fantasies transformers combine
cool kick-ass vehicles with giant alien
robots the show is about a war between
the Autobots led by Optimus Prime and
the Decepticons led by Megatron's ok it
sounds pretty Hardy but they gave us
exactly what we wanted transforming
robots being the crap out of each other
the great thing about this show is how
created they got with all these
different robots I mean I know they made
up half of these characters just to sell
more toys but the possibilities for
these things were just endless you have
trucks you have bikes and thank you
guns you had tape players well if that's
a little late but at the time it was
pretty good transformers hell it just
kicked ass number 5
but tick when all the superhero shows
out there
this was the satire that handled the
ludicrous nature of the genre of a pest
the show was about a big blue man who
literally comes out of nowhere to fight
crime nobody knows who he is or where he
came from including him all he knows is
that he wants to fight crime and shout
horrible cat phrases evildoers eat my
justice he has a simple mind very little
intelligence but luckily his neurotic
psychic aren't there is there to keep
him in line it was a great show because
it did such a good job mocking what most
kids were growing up with at the time in
the show they didn't have a secret
crying solving lair
they have an apartment I can barely hold
to the super villains aren't always rich
misunderstood madmen sometimes are just
children making death rays in their tree
houses put the main back demon wave make
me and the heroes don't always shout
good catchphrases sometimes they just
shout spoon okay well maybe it didn't
all make sense but this strange blend of
sir reality and reality made the show so
enjoyable to watch written half the time
more for adults as opposed to kids
granted the animation wasn't always
top-notch but it made up for it with its
great writing and bizarre sense of humor
the tick we all right justice sandwich
no toppings necessary what he said
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles looking
back I realized this is the stupidest
idea in the entire world I mean just
listen to the title
what lobotomize monkey came up with that
I mean it doesn't even seem real it
seems like a satire of another idea but
hey it took the world by storm me
included
why because I had action big animals and
of course a great sense of humor I mean
they handle fulfills the shredder for
crying out loud
I want this city to grovel at my feet
now all these freeloading parasites I
think what means this show so popular
that it was combining two things that
kids love animals and action scenes for
when some outdated catchphrases like
really righteous and you have a show
that's destined to be a hit I think what
really shocks me about this show is that
actually worked twice I mean they
released the show again recently and it
actually became a hit so much so that
they even made another movie based on it
I don't know who came up with this idea
or how well okay maybe I don't know how
but it doesn't matter this show was a
ton of fun combining everything that
kids loved at the time Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles an idea so stupid it has
to be good
number three
accident from one set of use to another
x-men was the comic book show that every
kid could enjoy why because it had a
million characters to choose from unlike
superhero shows like Superman or
spider-man x-men had a huge cast of main
characters so if you've been like one
main character
you had another you could watch if you
didn't way back here you could watch
somebody else on top of that it dealt
with an issue that a lot of kids know
too well prejudice every kid has to go
through a little bit of being a funnel
and you look different or acting
different chances are you've probably
got a lot of it an x-men was all about
that people who are ridiculed and
criticized simply because they were born
different it showed us how to live with
our gift and how not to hide what makes
us different but to embrace them and of
course I had some kick-ass action and
supermodels in spandex that always helps
to excellent gave us a ton of characters
that we won't soon be forgetting each
one with their own backstory in
psychological issues it was interesting
it was fun and they knew how to keep us
glued to the TV x-men the perfect showed
a sinker closet number two
Animaniacs I've never seen a show that
came so close to capturing the spirit of
the original Warner Brothers cartoons
like this one yeah Tiny Toons might have
started as bad but was Animaniacs I
perfected it with writing that could
entertain both children and adults alike
our generation didn't grow up with
Shobha Carol Burnett or laughing so this
is the closest thing to a variety show
we have combining great songs lovable
characters and ingenious comedic writing
the characters in this show seems so
real that they practically leaped off
the screen characters like the Warner is
like a squirrel and pinky in the brain
we're all hilarious constructs that knew
how to be likable as well as funny it
not only did a good job of making us
laugh but also educated us every once in
a while and actually made it fun that's
really hard to do that's a mousse with
easy I'm at Indianapolis IN I know now
forever that Rouge is the capital of
Louisiana the rest I don't know but it
is one of those kids shows I can still
watch as an adult it's still totally
enjoy it has an energy and a
sophistication that grew few other shows
hand
mostly because producer Steven Spielberg
gave a lot of freedom especially it was
also said he was present for the
majority of shows production out proving
once again that I think he makes it much
better producer than as a director
private writing is overrated but I
digress
Animaniacs was one of those rare shows
that allowed a lot of freedom that
really paid off to put it short it was
pure animated gold and the number one
animate nostalgic TV show is Batman an
animated series this is the show that
changed everything
it took chances it took a new look and
it took its audience seriously at a time
when most action cartoons look like GI
Joe or x-men and then took a totally
different approach with a focus on art
deco design it was one of the few shows
I had actual orchestra for the music and
it also got voice actors who didn't
sound like typical voice actors they
sounded like real people on top of that
Batman was dark
mixing high-flying action
psychological drama that the Batman
series is infamous for they didn't
always have happy endings and the bad
guys weren't always just bad guys
sometimes there are ordinary people like
you or me whose lives got destroyed by
tragic events that's not the kind of
kids programming most of us are used to
now that's not to say they didn't have
some real fans either characters like
the Joker were just as funny and
threatening as many of the film
renditions by the way did you know it's
a Luke Skywalker playing him what make
Batman so great is that it was its own
creation and yet somehow also embodied
all the previous incarnations before it
it had the drama from the comic books
the subtlety from the Burton movies and
even a little bit of the camp value from
the 60s show at Schumacher films it
seemed like the Batman that combined
everything and yet somehow seemed to
stand on its own its morals were dark
its characters complex and as endings
who are not always very cheerful we took
the show seriously because it took us
seriously they never put down to us or
lightly fantome because we were kids he
gave us the straight gothic stories that
we all know and are proof that the
legacy of the Dark Knight will always
live on all of this amorous white Batman
is the greatest anime a nostalgic TV
show I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
it so you don't have to
you